euromaxx highlights and here's your host
guy in hempstead hi there and welcome to
our euromaxx highlights of the past week
which this time around happens to
include the following top stories invoke
why jogging pants and sneakers are going
mainstream sweet tooth why Spain's Jordy
Rocca is the world's best pastry chef
and spray city how street artists are
brightening up the Polish city of
Katowice
and seeing as it is the weekend I
thought I'd dressed the part namely
relaxed with a comfy pair of jogging
pants and while I did pass on the
sneakers today dressing down for work
has become more of the norm in many many
workplaces partly because of course high
fashion has appropriated the look but
also maybe because people think that if
you're not restricted in what you wear
well then your mind should also be more
freed to be productive well no doubt a
lot of it is also down to personal
choice but we had a look at the new less
a fair style crop tops and jogging pants
with holes baggy sweaters with leggings
leather sport pants and silver sneakers
all showcased against the backdrop of a
supermarket karl lagerfeld's new
autumn/winter collection for chanel
shows how high fashion can be super
casual and the german designer is not
alone fashion house Gucci offers
sneakers for men in 75 different styles
an kenzo has been selling luxury
sweatshirts and Technicolor baseball
caps for the past two years designers
Umberto Leone and Carol Lim have
rejuvenated the label for years now
Berlin designer Michelle Michelle ski
has been specializing in sportswear
inspired fashion he says the new casual
look reflects the zeitgeist does
fishsticks of us from a lot today's
workplace demand speed flexibility and
mobility you need to be sporty basically
what you eat and you can express the
fact that you're fit and energetic
through the clothes you wear sportswear
and sneakers do that more effectively
than say a tailored suit from Savile Row
high fashion and streetwear until now
two completely different worlds but
Michelle ski is at home in both as
creative director for Adidas back in
2003 he worked with Japanese odd couture
designer Yohji Yamamoto luxury jogging
pants were one of his signature looks my
million buddy sweat pension sweatpants
have always been important in my life
they first surfaced at the end of the
80s when rave culture got going people
danced from Friday night till Monday
morning and so they needed clothes that
were comfortable and so they've always
been important for me a building block
in my personal wardrobe something
everyone should have a key heater or
harms loiter we meet up with GERD Muller
Tompkins on Dusseldorf upscale Koenig's
la as director of the German Institute
for fashion he analyzes developments in
the industry and predicts future trends
in his opinion even business executives
can adopt a more casual look these days
let's get ya from all stock typical I
don't have the statement this look makes
is I represent my product and a high
performance of my company and I don't
need to talk it up is it worth with a
pinstripe suit I'm showing myself as I
really am does my not as typhoon and so
when someone dresses down regardless of
those around him it conveys the
impression that they're confident
and that they can afford to do that is
he so quiet we a mine sister slice
sukoon the American tech industry is
partly driving the change in office
fashion the dress code in Silicon Valley
is definitely casual apple founder Steve
Jobs was famous for wearing sports shoes
whatever the occasion facebook CEO mark
zuckerberg is worth billions and wears a
hoodie the global booming computer
industry jobs has led to a change in
office dress codes around the world even
Chi Diekman chief editor of Germany's
popular tabloid Bild has undergone a
radical image revamp inspired by a nine
month stay in Silicon Valley
understatement is on vogue out on the
town but what about in the office it's
punishable we're not used to it but it's
not so unusual now it's good to relax a
little choking pants at the office no
therefore the gym not the office if you
want to be respected you need to portray
the right image Cooper comms but our
fashion pro predicts the casual look
will soon be normal in all walks of life
it was MIT are not via two or more it's
related to a change in values there's
more focus on being relaxed on feeling
good soft loose fitting clothing it
feels good to wear white but in
klamotten Alaska Tomlin wool through
character Michelle michalski believes
this sporty look we'll just be an
overnight trend but he says choosing the
right outfit is above all a question of
personal style and the environment you
work in little top brightly colored top
performance running shoes that you could
run a marathon with are perhaps not the
right thing for working in a bank but if
you work in a funky office or online
agency then it's bang on trend but
remembered in fashion it can take a lot
of effort to look like you don't care
well if Berlin always has a healthy
rivalry going on with the likes of kin
and Venice for the title of top European
Film Festival there's one thing that can
has that Berlin certainly doesn't and
that is always gorgeous weather there's
nothing quite like the Croisette in the
month of May for glamour when the Stars
can step out in their evening clothes
without fear of catching pneumonia and
whilst those 18 films in competition are
supposed to be the main event the
parties certainly give them a run for
their money it's the time of year when
the big names in cinema turn out in
style on the can waterfront and the
promenade des Lak was it it's a non-stop
party for 11 days and nights here on the
Kota zoo the atmosphere is lively but
lay back in keeping with Southern
Frances Mediterranean Flair you know the
light here is spectacular and I think
that really draws people from the movie
industry because it's so beautiful here
also you know everybody brings their
great films and it's a great sense of
camaraderie the camping festival is so
many things I mean not only just in
terms of movies movies that of course
there is an official competitions and at
the same time it's all the parties that
are going on and you know charities that
are going on and the models it's just a
huge entire monster that we all
participate in
there's a party for every preference
something for everyone the association
of German film producers can certainly
get down and groove and so can women in
film an organization that advocates
women's rights in the film industry
evenings like this evening is fantastic
because it does highlight the fact that
women do need to be celebrated and in
film oscar-winning German director ko
olina link has also taken time out for
con the all-night parties are one way to
unwind after a hard day of viewings and
public appearances sometimes she feels a
bit overwhelmed by the glitter and
glamour cinema demon oh my god I don't
even know where to start with all the
films and all the very important people
the screaming masses and dazzling starz
I've seen it before and my first
instinct is always just a runaway yep
done in Vienna on floor texting that's
not a bad idea with Mel Gibson sylvester
stallone arnold schwarzenegger and
harrison ford rumbling down the
croisette on an armored personnel
carrier to promote their new movie we
found a former James Bond villain who
would have been happy to hitch a ride
going down the quest set on a tank with
stallone and schwarzenegger and all
these guys so if that was the further i
mean it would have blown my mind but
this place is still very elegant and
classy each year exclusive Swiss
jewelers try to outshine one another
with the most elegant party in can
Hollywood star Cate Blanchett and
assorted super models lined up to
present the latest collections of
watches and earrings
but aesthetics isn't it it's about the
whole you know presentation therefore
you know fashion makes people look for
certain characters to have a great move
you have to do a great red carpet and
you can do a great red carpet without a
great amazing dress and jewelry but the
starlet's by no means have a monopoly on
the dazzling can many parties here are
works of art in their own right
experiences for all the senses the
guests are here for something new unique
and super exclusive
it brings out all the luminaries
throughout the world and you know it
just it just makes everyone feel good
and it's art it's about our so that type
of art without art really believe all
the Hollywood swinging stars dumb to
care and they'll be painting can read
into the weekend when the most
extravagant of all of the parties will
be held to announce the winner of the
pie mwah well he's one of the reasons
tourists will travel the extra mile to
eat in girona in northeastern Spain
Jordi Rocca as his name implies is a
little bit of a rock star in the
culinary world the Catalan native was
just voted world's best patissier by
Britain's restaurant magazine and many
do agree with the critics that his
avant-garde approach to sweet treats
proves that the devil is in the desert
a dessert that seems to breathe to serve
his sour dough ice cream with light
cheese and cocoa bean puree Johnny Rocco
doesn't use a normal plate but a plastic
construction that rises and falls the
pastry chef wants every dessert to Utley
surprise his guests pasta scenarios
aquel que que llega an extraordinary
dessert has to move and give you more
than just the flavor good desserts tell
you a story much more important than how
its prepared in tastes is the feeling it
conveys yeah I said emocion shawdy ronca
doesn't limit himself to addressing the
taste buds alone using the ingredients
from his creation new valle de Mona
which means cloud of lemons he's created
a sense that he serves guests along with
the desert it's wonderful maybe another
day my ta dadada the scent is
reminiscent of melting butter and bag
ammonia a bit like mile end times yeah
like roasted citrus fruits butter and
flour I live in to pass the airport area
for the past 15 years shortyrocky and
his brothers have been making meals for
guests at el celler de can roca in
Sharon are near Barcelona Spain it has
three Michelin stars and last year
Britain's restaurant magazine named it
the world's best restaurant the kitchen
crew made a name for itself for
avant-garde ideas and they often
originated with the pastry chef varsity
Jordi is the craziest of us all in a
positive sense he comes up with our most
unusual creations he's quite an asset
for our kitchen get him one without his
ideas a lot of our dishes would not be
possible since Russia as Luis Potosi
less caffeine was put non-aryan [ __ ]
Riot's in 2012 the 36 year old opened a
second restaurant in G Roma's old city
the furnishings in the ice cream parlor
Vokoun burlesque a bit reminiscent of
the film Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory and here you don't need a
reservation so no antenna look at the
agility after year the ice cream parlor
is a kind of window to everything we
make in as salir de can roca we always
say a bit of the spirit of our desserts
is present in every portion of ice cream
we sell and the shop is a window because
all kinds of people come here young and
old alike and everyone likes it
with more than 30 toppings and sauces
each customer can put together his own
customized treat the ice cream comes in
such unusual flavors as rose parmesan
cheese and roasted bread Jory rockers
best sellers are his ice cream cakes
which he calls bunnies is an alligator
with but there's no Maggie no you're not
putting me there this here is a very
special machine hello it's kisses whoo
yeah it enables us to seal the cake
while we bake it briefly at a very high
temperature that we were we put there if
we got in a cake is then very hot
outside I think it inside the ice cream
is still cold when you either esta
caliente por fuera better stay with Lyon
and lavaca and the proof is in the
eating it's better than a love of car
these bits of chocolate really explode
in your mouth it's a sweet sensation and
transports you to another dimension mins
gun when it's very good really very good
fab scrumptious yes it's really good
in girona jolly rocker is treated like a
pop star but amid all the photo ops and
press conferences what's most important
are his desserts whether in his elite
three-star restaurant or his more
egalitarian ice cream parlor
well now onto an art form that always
hovers somewhere in that gray zone
between legality and illegality and that
is street art but what started out as
the graffiti of social and political
rebellion has long since evolved into a
respected JAMA that not only fetches
high prices with collectors but also up
the cultural credentials of a city like
Katowice in southern Poland it's home to
just a few thousand people in the city
proper but the greater urban area boasts
about 2.7 million and so it's a busy
place to be and currently something of
an open-air canvas as its annual street
art festival paints the town katowice
population just over 300,000 is in
southern poland traditionally it's an
industrial and mining city not known for
its beauty in recent years it's been
increasingly used as an open-air gallery
the catch of each say street art
festival puts off the wall art on the
walls of drab apartment buildings for
instance this is the fourth year the
festival is being held
mom Poonam Turkish Shadow Moses took a
street art of us that's the vibrant art
is perfectly suited to post industrial
cities like this one last post
industrial neck and IP r dot they stuck
with many people you have to get me used
to consuming aunt us forge an ellipse
another street art is ideal for that
because it's at home and the spaces
people live any [ __ ] shoshoni nice key
the festival keeps artists working in
and around Katowice for ten days though
some projects take longer sergeyevitch
has been at work on the first part of
his plans series on the seven deadly
sins for two weeks now this one is sloth
he doesn't work out the idea for his
painting until he's on site I need
always to saw as a wall because it's
like public place and it's all walls
health structure has a like its natural
material I need to saw it and understand
what this what needs this wall even with
all the turmoil in his home country
ukraine he doesn't watch his current
work to convey any political message
he's creating it in Poland for Polish
viewers outdoors and free of charge it's
a public place where you can make it for
people for two to solve the reaction to
communicate with them to to collaborate
with them to try to manipulate with them
it's it's nice because it's real life
it's you can connect have some
connection it's it's cool the first
street art festival here took place in
2011 well-known artists from the world
over have taken part the spanish artist
studies for example his hand is now
something of a festival trademark the
image was even brought to life for a
promotional video
another street art store is Spanish
artist a thief he painted this light
switch on a prefab luck in 2012 the lego
movie doesn't have to be on my building
but still it's a good idea that's the
financing tool everybody is dead i'll
bet em i always like to ride my bike
around town during the festival and look
at everything it's great yeah stop so
giving you the feelings brilliant
especially the hen a great idea soaking
from the forest lead of justice squares
or many say street artists vandalism but
this is something very different this is
a billion rakhna tell me suck it up
there's a new picture on a tunnel over
there horrible no I think of it as the
tunnel of fear what is it Corriveau
vertical all the city is much more
colorful than it used to be near sasha
grey around us is disappearing but
wealth evoke the festival includes an
exhibition on the history of street art
in poland it had its beginnings in the
1980s but it's more popular now than
ever before it started as a form of
protest against the communist regime
nah publicist Toriyama street art in
this country is closely tied to the
history of solid arash the major polish
opposition movement of that time vada
papa me and that's potassium a
particularly work of Dalek Petrovsky
started showing up in the late 1980s and
became well known that would suck for
example or Lenin with ammo he gave them
to this day many people in Poland see it
as a kind of icon Oh Dada capita kofsky
go a total of 14 artists are taking part
this year funded mostly by the city of
Katowice Sasha Kormos also from Ukraine
works on his abstract statistics he's
well aware that in a few years it will
have faded or been painted over you and
me have some short life and every people
who live in this beautiful years also
have limited in life so it's normally if
your art piece also have limit in time
it's not problem for me it's not problem
for people i don't think about you must
make something special for all times
next year katowice will be celebrating
its 150th birthday and to mark the
occasion its fifth street art festival
will add yet a little more color to the
city once again and finally as spring
morphs into summer we'll finish off with
a visit to Leeds Castle that's near the
village of leads in the county of Kent
in southern England now considered by
many to be one of the most impressive
castles in the world it was an Anglo
American heiress who turned the 9th
century stronghold into a gardeners
paradise and many flower lovers are
still thanking her for it to this very
day
Spring has arrived at the gardens of
leeds castle
situated in the hills of the county of
Kent leeds castle is surrounded by lush
parks and meadows Samantha be spies on
her way to the cottage gun it's still
early in the morning the gardener loves
this time of day before the visitors
stream in coming to work every day is a
tacular Singh view it's been called the
most beautiful castle in the world and
it's a very beautiful garden we're very
lucky to have different types we have a
cottage garden we have a woodland garden
we have Mediterranean God so that
there's a lot of variety so we can deal
with a lot plants and a lot of different
aspects and it is exciting cottage
garden used to be the kitchen garden
where vegetables were grown
today peacock strut around no one's hens
pecks the ground in 1926 the entire
estate was bought by a wealthy and low
American Air ass it was privately owned
by late Bailey she she was able to put
money in and concentrate on making the
gardens look beautiful and spectacular
for her for her own personal reasons the
picturesque home of olive lady Bailey
was once the country estate of English
kings from Richard the second to Henry
the eighth several of those owners left
leads to their respective wives it
became known as ladies castle the last
private owner lady Bailey died in 1974
she bequeathed leads to a charitable
trust that opened it to the public many
of the flowers in the exuberant floral
arrangements grow right here although
half a million people come and visit
each year there is still some tranquil
corners on the faster state
a daily show involving birds of prey is
a big attraction
bully pretty
I need to the king
leeds castle is popular with families
daily tours through the mediterranean
and cottage gardens are a huge draw is
difficult god the gardens of leeds
castle are a magnet for visitors and
many comes several times a year is going
to be so interesting to see it
throughout seasons but at the moment is
love stunning it really is worth a visit
I like the English style you know with
all the flowers they're all mixed up and
I love it this is not so disciplined
just like the gardens we have in France
so I found it so beautiful I've been
coming here since I was 14 which I'm 73
so I've been coming to leeds castle will
good many years now before it was ever
open to the public he used to creep in
under fence 40-odd years ago I lived in
the local village and you know even then
when we weren't allowed in here because
it was not open till nineteen
seventy-six I think you still would look
from the road and think I'd like to be
in there I want to go in there and see
it and it has that feeling it has it's a
magnetism laws it's a magnetism that
makes leeds castle and its gardens such
a very special place
I'll feel free to visit our website if
you'd like to see some of those reports
again and with that our time is up so
until we meet again all the rest from us
here in Berlin and thanks for watching
tus ojitos in bye bye
you